>> NEARLY HALF OF ALL THE
HOMELESS PEOPLE LIVING IN THE
STREETS IN AMERICA HAPPEN TO
LIVE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING TO OUR
BEAUTIFUL CALIFORNIA IS A
DISGRACE TO OUR COUNTRY.
IT'S A SHAME, THE WORLD IS
LOOKING AT IT, LOOK AT
LOS ANGELES WITH THE TENTS AND
THE HORRIBLE DISGUSTING
CONDITIONS.
>> Laura: THERE ARE A LOT OF
TENTS IN D.C. AS WELL BUT
CALIFORNIA CERTAINLY HAS THE
MOST.
THAT WAS THE PRESIDENT AND THE
DEMOCRATS FAILED TO RESPOND TO
HOMELESSNESS.
HERE NOW IS L.A. MEDICINE
SPECIALIST DR. DREW PINSKY,
EXPLAIN WHY THIS SHOULD HAVE
BEEN A TOPIC AT THE DEMOCRATIC
DEBATE LAST NIGHT.
>> IT WAS NOT A TOPIC OF DEBATE
BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY THE
HOMELESS SITUATION IN CALIFORNIA
IS DIRECTLY THE RESULT OF FAILED
POLICIES HERE.
THIS IS NOT A HOUSING PROBLEM.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES HAVE
A HOUSING STRUCTURE THAT THEY
ARE SUPPORTING, THIS IS NOT A
HOUSING PROBLEM.
THIS IS A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES
NOT HAVE SPECIFIC JURISDICTION
OVER MENTAL HEALTH IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
THE CONGRESS OCCASIONALLY HAS
TIPTOED TOWARD THE CARE OF THE
MENTALLY ILL.
PREVIOUS PRESIDENTS HAD VETOED
THAT UNTIL PRESIDENT KENNEDY WHO
PASSED A COMMUNITY HEALTH ACT
WHICH WAS DESIGNED TO STRANGLE
THE STATE MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
SINCE THEN, WE HAVE HAD DECAY OF
OUR MENTAL HEALTH PROVISIONS FOR
THE CHRONICALLY MENTALLY ILL.
THEY ARE ALL ON THE STREETS, I
SPENT THE DAY THERE ON SUNDAY
AND 100% OTHER THAN THE
CRIMINALS THAT I SAW PREYING ON
THE HOMELESS, 100% OF THE PEOPLE
IN THE STREETS WERE EITHER MAJOR
MENTAL ILLNESS OR DRUG
ADDICTION, 100%.
I TALKED TO DOZENS OF PEOPLE AND
THEY ALL TOLD ME THE SAME THING.
EVERYONE IS ON DRUGS -- NO
SURPRISE THERE.
THIS IS THE OTHER THING THEY ARE
NOT PREPARING FOR, THEY SAID THE
SAME THING OVER AND OVER AGAIN,
THIS NUMBER CAME UP MULTIPLE
TIMES.
50% OF THE PEOPLE OUT HERE WILL
REFUSE CARE NO MATTER WHAT YOU
OFFER THEM, NO MATTER HOW GOOD
THE SERVICES, THAT'S BECAUSE
THIS IS A MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE
AND PART OF HAVING THIS
CONDITION MUCH LIKE IF YOU HAD
DEMENTIA, YOU LOSE INSIGHT INTO
WHAT IS GOING ON AND YOU BECOME
ATTACHED TO THE CIRCUMSTANCES
YOU ARE IN.
YOU HAVE TO EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF DISABLED, WE HAVE
TO MODIFY PROP 47, THESE ARE
FAILED POLICIES.
IT MOVES PEOPLE OUT AND INTO
CARE, THEY ARE DYING ON THE
STREETS AND MY CONSTANT REFRAME
TO EVERYONE OF THEM IS HOW MANY
BODIES IN THE STREETS BEFORE
THEY ARE WILLING TO CHANGE THE
POLICY?
>> Laura: THEY TALK ABOUT THE
CONCERNS AT THE BORDER AND THEY
ARE REAL BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
GO TO THE BORDER.
TWO BLOCKS FROM RIGHT HERE, WHEN
YOU COME TO D.C., TWO BLOCKS
FROM RIGHT HERE THERE ARE PEOPLE
SHOOTING UP, OUT ON THE
STREET -- AND PEOPLE JUST DRIVE
BY.
THIS IS D.C. GOVERNMENT, ITS
LOCAL AND STATE GOVERNMENTS.
WE ARE OUT OF TIME.